Prince Harry's wedding - Megan Markel is
just two days away from our Kroll
becoming a royal will mean immersing
herself in British culture and customs
she's expected to adopt the code of
etiquette associated with royal life
Markel and American also plans to become
a citizen of the UK and that means
passing a test where she may have to
know facts like how early pubs are open
in England it's 11:00 a.m. that's the
answer and who the fifth wife of Henry
the 8th was the answer is Catherine
Howard Charlie d'Agata is in Windsor
England with a look at what it takes to
become a British royal Charlie good
morning good morning this is called the
Long Walk for obvious reasons and
believe it or not Prince Harry and Megan
just drove by and gave us a wave now
this is where the procession will lead
back to the castle on the wedding day a
day that will change Megan's life
forever falling in love with a prince
was the easy part
but the moment Megan Marco slips on that
ring Her Royal Highness takes on the
role of a lifetime I love the way when
she was interviewed she kept talking
about the role journalist Alastair Bruce
is also a family friend of the Royals
and to understand being a part of the
royal family and therefore serving the
Queen as a role is a huge advantage I
think she's gonna be great but being
great demands a mastery of protocol and
perfect etiquette for starters who to
curtsy to she curtsies for the Queen
Prince Phillip Prince Charles Duchess
Camilla and William and Kate Princess
Alexandra yes Michael of Kent no
princesses Beatrice and Eugenie yes
unless Prince Harry is in the room in
which case Megan pulls rank and they
curtsy to her welcome to the Royal Court
former royal Butler grant Harold
remembers his first introduction into
that world you very much become an
ambassador told that from that day
forward everything you see in do
reflects which is true no that's for for
something myself for some of you that
are actually married the family I mean
very much there's more than an
ambassador you know you're part of it
and that means some changes
no more selfies no more autographs all
these kind of things she's got to stop
because Royals doing daughter grafts
then
celebrities and that's a rule and that's
a rule and she'll have to pass one test
even immigration lawyers call insanely
complex for Megan Marco it'll take more
than just marrying a prince to become
British she plans to gain her
citizenship and that will mean taking
the life in the UK test it covers
everything from literature to politics
to yes
gardening it's one of the country's most
popular pastimes in Kew Gardens one of
its most famous botanical spaces home to
the most diverse collection of living
plants in the world the majesty of
London Symphony Orchestra what better
way to illustrate the importance of
classical music to English culture now
you may not have heard of names like
Gustav Holst or Ralph Vaughan Williams
but Megan will have to know the names of
those composers to get past questions on
arts and culture
[Music]
looking across to the houses of
parliament the very center of political
power here in the UK
Megan will have to learn the ins and
outs of the British government but she
may face more obscure questions like the
height of the London Eye 443 feet to be
exact and history of course lots of
history like which 800 year old
documents set the foundation for British
Parliament the Magna Carta housed here
at the British Library even actual
British people struggled to answer some
of the questions st. Andrews the patron
saint of which country who is the fifth
wife of Henry the eighth
who invaded England in 1066 which didn't
exactly fill me with confidence when I
took the citizenship test myself last
week I was so hard okay here's the
moment I passed god save the queen
marrying into any family can be a bit
daunting for any bride but this one
comes with an especially steep learning
curve well it's a learning curve that
anybody can take on you know if you love
someone you learn anything and if you've
got someone who you love besides you
you'll be able to learn it and if it is
true that love conquers all the prince
and his princess bride might just live
happily ever after a person who knows
the couple told us has been a lot of
discussion about how Megan fits into the
royal family but what about the other
way around she's a strong individual a
political activist she may change the
way people view the Royals Nora ooh
Charlie d'Agata and Windsor I like that
point then maybe that she can kind of
shake things up inside the family all
families are a blend they know their
blend in the new one congratulations
also on him passing the test
yeah yeah and you can see how Charles
owned where a lesson went on CBS this
morning Tom calm he took a tea Attica
class with former royal Butler grant
Harold do you like how I always put on
my British I think that gets you a
couple of points on the test